hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game from round five of the
Greinke chess classic this game lasted
over seven hours I believe it's seven
hours and nine minutes to be exact
we have Fabiano Caruana with the white
pieces and - with the black pieces and
like I said it's a very exciting game
and as usual it's this game like
finished five minutes ago so I'm just
gonna show it to you I don't have any
photos of the event yet I will show you
the photos understandings probably
tomorrow morning as I will show another
game from this round but for now I just
want to show you this game because it
features one of the most amazing tactics
so far in this tournament and maybe
maybe even further it's really it's
really quite a beauty Fabi has the white
pieces and he opens with E 4 we have E 5
Knight to f3 and Knight to f6
even goes for the Petrov defense so
using the fabi's weapon against him a
knight captures we have d6 Knight back
to f3 and the Knight captures on e4 and
the Knight to c3 something people have
been using lately to try and get
advantage with White Knight captors and
see 3d captures on c3 and now Bishop to
e7 a bunch of 3 3 we have castles Queen
to d2 Knight to d7 and the queenside
castle Knight to f6 h3 and not allowing
Bishop to g4 c5 and Bishop to f4 now
Bishop to e6 and now a3 a3 seems like an
interesting seems like an interesting
move
I don't know in in positions like like
these I always go King b1 I kind of
don't want my king in my queen on the
same diagonal and if black ever decides
to go Queen if I've only done well I
maybe if I'm forced I will go a3
so a3 you know this is top chess d5
Knight to g5 and the Bishop to d7 are
not allowing Fabi to capture the Bishop
g4
and Bishop to c6 eyeing that rook on h1
Bishop to g2 and now rook to e8 Queen to
d3 i pressuring that h7 point so this
knight on f6 can't really move Bishop to
d6 and here Bishop to Queen to g3
pressuring now the bishop on d6 and also
basically forcing the exchange of
bishops you don't you don't want to play
a move like Queen to d2 to simply
protect the bishop because then h6 wins
the game for black
I simply attack the knight Knight of
three and now comes the knife 3 for you
attack the Queen the Queen has to keep
an eye on the f2 pawn otherwise you get
for example Queen d3 you get this nice
fork both Brooks and the Queen I only
Square where that you can protect is e 3
and E 1 and after you do this Knight g3
attack the Queen from the rook you pick
up this rook and you even don't even
have to pick up the rookies if white
plays I feel like Queen to d2
you can go Bishop captures on f4 and
after Queen captures an ID to check now
again wins the Queen so Allah a lot of
poison to this Queen to g3 definitely
the strongest move Bishop captures Queen
captures and now h6 Knight to f3 and
queen to b8 - forces an exchange of
Queens
well not forcing it but you know there's
really not a bright square for the Queen
so captures captures and now Knight to
d2 Fabi has to activate somehow this
night doesn't really have any good
squares from f3 and this Bishop isn't
really doing anything unless this Knight
moves so night to d2 but this allows
rook to e2 so infiltrating already on
the second-ranked attacking the f2 pawn
and now rook to f1 defending it and here
even plays b6 b6 seems like an odd move
since you do have a route kanuto so why
not double up immediately problem is if
you do this then White has this option
of pushing c4 you don't want to capture
on c4 then Bishop captures Bishop you're
gonna have triple spawns and the c-file
wife and simply gobble them up whenever
he wants to
so you'd have to push d4 and after
captures captures and let's say b4
captures captures
you're gonna have to go back from the
e-file so doubling up and e-file was
just a waste of a move so in this
position even goes B 6 now rook to e1
offering an exchange of rooks rook to e8
now
rook captures rook captures and now came
to d1 kicking the rook back rook to e6
and now F for King to a fate even was to
get her King into the game rook to e1
King 37 now captures captures and King
to e2 so we look at this position the
material is completely equal one thing
you you can immediately notice is the
Fabi has doubled pawns on the C file and
that his King is slightly more active so
all in all black black is slightly
better g5 f capture some g5 h captures
on g5 and now Knight to f3 attacking the
g5 pawn Knight to e4 defending the pawn
and now King to e3 f6 now defending the
g5 phone once more by the f6 pawns on
other night you can move Bishop to f1
and now Knight to d6 night to d2 now f5
captures cap captures by the knight a
king to f2 and now Knight sir King to e5
and now Knight to f3 check King to a4
and now you can see that the black king
is already extremely active so nice to
e1 see for now not allowing night to d3
check also limiting the mobility of this
Bishop on f1 night the g2 check now King
to e5 and Bishop to e2 Bishop to a for
attacking the c2 pawn bishop d1
defending Bishop to e8 and now Bishop to
g4 but rip to g6 now threatening and
discoveries to grab the CC to pawn
bishop three two and now
knight Knight to d6 again attacking the
pawn nice to III not defending the c2
pawn and now Knight to e4 check King f3
and now Knight to f6 King to f2 Bishop
to f7 9th to g2 and now Bishop to e6
attacking the pawn h4 94 check King
moves and now Bishop to h3
pawn captures Knight captures with check
King to g3 Bishop captures and g2 King
captures on g2 and night to e6 and this
is now a very very dangerous position
for white as you can see it's very it's
very hard to defend these pawns
Ethan's plan is nice to see five and
ninth to a four and from there the night
will be attacking the beat upon which
cannot be defended by the bishop because
it's on a dark square and also if you
push it then C 3 will become a permanent
weakness for example if you push B 3
then after B 5 captures captures again
you have this week c3 pawn and it will
it will fall very soon so King to f2 we
have a knight to c5 as planned
Bishop to h5 nice to a4 not even trying
to defend it Bishop 28 and the knight
capture some B - king - E - a 6 now we
have King - D - and now B 5 Bishop to h5
Knight to a4 Bishop trace f7 and this is
move 59 so this is where you have to
make one more move to gain to reach the
second time control and here of course
the question is do push deeper or do you
not pull v4 before immediately does give
black some additional winning chances
after C capture screen captures you do
have to play something King to D 1 C 3
and now King to C 1 and now it's it's
definitely a question can black actually
win this it's very hard to say but even
didn't want to commit to this as if she
does have to make one more move to
actually start doing something but she
played knife to c5 and here we have King
to c1 and here patrol Eiko made an
interesting observation he said that now
that a move 60 has been made she could
have simply played knight back to a4
allow the hunter King to repeat and then
use her time to calculate d4
but yeah that's I mean he's a very very
you know experienced guy so nice - he
six trying to now go all around with the
knight King to be - Knight to f4 Bishop
28 King to e4 and Bishop to c6 now in 3
3 D it is well the ideal idea is would
be in 2 D 2 and then use the Knights to
pick up these two points without this
Bishop actually
having too many of your own points and
here Fabi makes the mistake that almost
cost him the game here he plays Bishop
to b7 Bishop to b7 is a blunder that
loses the game but it's extremely
interesting how it loses the game
so here's the position feel free to
pause the video and find the winning
move for e fun I will give it a couple
of seconds but feel free to use feel
free to use five minutes even to do it
as it's it's extremely interesting I
don't think I don't think even five
minutes is enough but you know you could
maybe maybe just give it like a minute
or two so even if you don't find it you
would be it will be very impressed when
you see what's going on here here the
reason Bishop to b7 is a mistake it
seems like this Bishop is now gonna
gobble up all these points but King to
d2 actually wins
now after Bishop captures on a6 now you
play Knight the d3 check and now you're
in a whole other whole lot of pain
because after you capture you what do
you play now now comes d4 and now
anything-anything wins for black I play
pawn captures on c4 then you get
captures with check King moves check
moves check and you grab the Queen and
you win the game if you don't if you
don't go like this doesn't doesn't
matter even if you capture this point
and simply push the pawn to c3 again
wins he moves really matter and
everything wins here
so after this King to d2 and the Bishop
captures Knight to b3 check you you
obviously can't capture the night but
even if you don't capture the night even
if you play something like King to be
one again Knight the e1 is coming and
now after Bishop captures Knight
captures on c2 Bishop attacks pawn now
comes nicely three defending the pawn
and still your king is gonna capture the
c3 pawn king defense now comes d4 with
the same idea you capture you push c3
and you queen your own pawn so a
brilliant brilliant maneuver this King
to d2 but both Fabi and even missed it
so here even played a5
first getting her pawn to a dark square
and only then maybe she thought she
would
do something I don't know as like I said
the game lasted over seven hours I don't
think I'll be doing an interview at
least not today but if they will if I
find one after I make this video I will
put all the links as usual in the
description below
soaking to see one we have Knight to e2
Czech king moves king to d2 but should
capture some d5 Knight captures on c3
Bishop attacks the pawn on b5 now we
have 91 check King b1 and knife to e3
Bishop to e4 you you don't really have
the option of capturing here because now
comes Knight captures on c2 and white is
lost if you capture the pawn you get
Knight captures here this comes with
check you lose the bishop and the a pawn
will win the game so after 93 bunch of
three four and here this is move 70 it's
it certainly seems like there should be
a way to win this position would black
and I mean black is so much better here
white can basically just move the bishop
around on this diagonal and there's
simply no way to win it so of course
even tried as she did work very hard for
this game finally she decided to push C
3 but now Bishop moves Knight to c4
attacks the pawn king defense pawn and
now even will basically try every
possible square for her Knight here to
try something but there is no there is
no way to do this because as you can see
there is no way to ever capture this
pawn the bishop and the King will always
defend it and there's no other way to
break through in this position so they
did play a couple of more moves we have
here try it a couple of more ideas now
even a four was pushed and yeah after
the knight tried all of the squares now
now here finally nice the c6 was played
and here an exchange of bones was made
so finally I grabbed the c2 point but it
doesn't matter can be three checks
Knight moves back it goes here and now
finally c2 and after pushing c2 they
finally agreed to a draw after seven
hours and nine minutes
so definitely definitely a wild game and
this entire game even had the upper-hand
completely dominated the entire game but
yeah that one that one moment when Bobby
played Bishop to b7 as she had this
chance of linking to d2 and win the game
but you know who would who would
possibly see this so yeah hopefully some
of you saw that if you have to share
your great success in the comments
comment section below I would like to
thank Martin Kristensen and William
Avery for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you tomorrow
morning
with another game from from the grant HS
classic thank you